in the world of gaming and movies the
bigger the monster the more fascinating
it is to learn more about them we want
to showcase to you these monsters in
different categories because sometimes
it's like comparing apples and oranges
in this video we will bring forth the
seven different monsters from games and
movies that are the size of planets we
have excluded anime monsters since some
of them are the size of the universe
itself it was pretty hard to find out
planet sized monsters since they are so
rare many of the most famous monsters
are in the size range of 100 to 300 feet
or around 30 to 90 meters in height
anyway do subscribe for more videos and
click on a notification bell so let's
continue on this list number seven the
brethren moons from the gaming wall of
dead space comes to brethren moons for
you who have never played dead space
that now is the perfect time to check it
out so back to the monster the brethren
moons are gigantic spacefaring
Necromorphs which are discovered to be
the source of the market signals they
are believed to be the final lifecycle
stage of the Necromorphs the brethren
moons though their origins are unknown
are a series of moon sized creatures
throughout the galaxy that consumes all
organic life they encountered through
the use of their markers the moons
consumed new worlds by sending our black
markers which travel through space and
time venom back on planets they are
somewhere in the range of 3,000 to 3,500
kilometers in diameter excluding the
long tentacles that come out from the
bottom number 6 ego a movie monster or a
celestial he was seen in guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 he was a celestial of
primordial and an extremely powerful
being as well as the biological father
of star-lord a ruthless megalomaniac
possessing a god complex ego only
desired to find some meaning in life and
then attempted to do so by conquering
the entire universe via an ominous title
extinction event known as the expansion
which would terraform all
life-sustaining planets vile in planning
the alien seedlings two extensions of
himself ego was able to use his
molecular manipulation to create a shell
around himself which offer millions of
years he evolved into a planet
the planet was no larger than the
Earth's moon so his almost around 2005
hunters which would put him close to the
brethren moons in size number five
bahama Kotal making its appearance in
Starship Troopers tree Marauders this is
the God book of the arachnids the
supreme leader bahama coddle is a
colossal life-form which is connected to
the cross of the planet om one the
planet may be the arachnids place of
origin this massive creature is deeply
rooted into the planet it is deployed
upon and possesses numerous appendages
beneath this planet's surface which it
uses to capture and kill prey the
Fisher's it creates are capable of
engulfing beings anywhere on the planet
and above attacks prey and fortunate
enough to fall into them depending on
the size of the planet for m1 then this
God bug can expand to envelop the entire
surface of the planet number 4 Sargeras
in Warcraft and World of Warcraft gaming
universe Sargeras was adopt god of
chaotic magic a demonic Titan who
created the Burning Legion
Sargeras created this vast demonic army
to scour all creation the Burning Legion
moves from world to world annihilating
everything in its path with devastating
fel magic no one knows exactly how many
worlds and mortal civilizations the
demons have annihilated in their unholy
burning crusade
Sargeras is a huge being almost beyond
comprehension he is fully clad in a
burning suit of molten black armor with
wild dancing flames running his head and
a form of thick massive hand sweeping
beer a pair of horns composed of
viciously hooked Bob's de-stem from the
crown of his head although many
different incarnations of him have been
seen his true form is said to be the
size of the planet as wrought itself
number 3 gongoon wiesen another gaming
monster on the list and taken from the
game Asura's Wrath he is the second
biggest entry from the gaming category
and his name is wiesen he is one of the
former eight garden generals and the
powerhouse of the seven deities wiesen
is the tallest and largest member of the
seven-day TS he wears a crimson and
yellow baggy pants with a purple sash
and a vest matching the same colors
wiesen also possesses a high level of
girth to match his size when he
transformed into his godlike state
Gungan wiesen it grants him a tremendous
enhancement making him as big as Gaia
itself and immensely augmenting his
already massive strength durability and
power to incalculable heights estimates
put him around 12,000 to 13,000
kilometers number 2 Unicron incredibly
the boss the size of a planet isn't the
biggest boss we have encountered in
video games the title of the most
mind-numbingly sanity breakingly huge
boss goes to Unicron the Decepticon mega
boss that appears in PlayStation 2
transformers the planet-sized transform
is one of the earliest creations of the
universe and the arch-nemesis of the
planet Cybertron as its shape shifts and
uses its powerful beams to try and
destroy the home wall of the orbits with
Optimus Prime being so large himself
scaling Unicron is difficult but
comic-book law estimates anyway between
30,000 and 120,000 kilometers in
diameter or 18,000 to 75,000 miles wide
that puts Unicron somewhere between the
planets of Neptune and Saturn
surprisingly in the movie Transformers
the last night Unicron was hinted to be
the planet Earth itself so he is way
smaller than his gaming version and the
number 1 spot goes to Galactus in 2007
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
Galactus was a cosmic entity born with
the universe itself he preserves the
balance of life by eating planets just
as a lion dust by eating antelopes
he sends his Herald Silver Surfer who
entered his service in exchange for
sparing his planet so he is sent along
the galaxies to search for suitable
planets for Galactus to consume when a
surfer finds earth Galactus is caught by
his servant and he travels the whole
universe to reach him but when he
arrives the Silver Surfer faces a change
of heart and faces his master and
releases all at once the cosmic power
Galactus gave him thus destroying him
Galactus was seemed to be bigger than
ten earths in the movie which means he
is the size of Jupiter
more than a hundred twenty thousand
kilometers or 75,000 miles so this
concludes the list of planets ice gaming
and movie monsters do check out our
other videos